I so understand I get it dope with my
kids this is not okay they didn't sign
up for this yeah it's sad it's hard so
hard I know I know but you're gonna get
through you you got it you got it now
Drew Barrymore in tears talking about
our kids with Pamela Anderson I just
spend every waking moment with them I
wake up with them I go to sleep with
them I have my weekends with them Pam
joins the Drew Barrymore show for a
candid conversation about her Memoir and
Netflix documentary and the 290s icons
Bond over doing the most to protect
their children I mean he's such a great
kid and so creative Pam shares two sons
Brandon and Dylan with her ex-husband
Tommy Lee while Drew has two daughters
Olive and Frankie with her ex will
copelman the one thing I tried to nail
is that if my kids come first no matter
what hot mess it is it'll it'll be okay
because the kid kids came first when I
had my kids it was like
that changed everything well the things
you won't do for yourself you do for
your kids and are we protecting our
children the way that we never got to
have that protection right definitely
definitely I hired I hired um it's funny
my kids didn't know they had a security
guard at school I hired someone to be an
assistant PE instructor yeah just to be
there because people were trying to take
them off the schoolyard I had to find
clever ways to kind of make them feel
everything was normal but I needed to
know eyes were on them and not you know
and I was not going to take that chance
that's when the actress breaks down
I so understand I get it dope with my
kids this is not okay they didn't sign
up for this yeah it's sad it's hard so
hard I know I know but you're gonna get
through you you got it you got it now
but Drew says she relates with Pam in
more ways than motherhood there's so
many parallels I know deal with you in
the Baywatch alum's new documentary The
activist gets real about heartbreak and
the difficulty of finding love after her
split from Tommy in 1995. I think what
it all comes down to is that I never cut
over
not being able to make it work with the
father of my kids
and
even though I thought I could
recreate a family or fall in love with
somebody else
it's just not me
so I think that's probably why I keep
failing in all my relationships it seems
like she's still in love with him she
will say he's the love of her life and
you know she's very respectful Tommy's
married and a very happy marriage and
she's very respectful of that marriage
but the thing I love about Pamela she is
a hopeless romantic through and through
that's why our film is called Pamela
love story no matter how many times it
doesn't work out for her she's going to
continue looking for romantic love
that's hard isn't it
it's just that connection that you don't
have with anybody else and people may
say that they can get past it but I
can't I haven't been able to and that's
okay I don't even care if I'm alone the
rest of my life I've experienced really
wonderful loving moments and sometimes
things don't last forever for a reason
and it's it's okay it's fine it's okay
in the last year I spent alone I think
it's been the happiest year of my life
and with the success of her doc fans are
petitioning for Pam to join the cast of
White Lotus season three possibly as the
sister of Jennifer coolidge's character
Tanya two macaroons
yeah great I really did only eat three
Pam admits she hasn't watched the series
but would she be down I just want to
push myself so I think that would be an
incredible challenge Pam and Drew's full
chat airs Friday
[Music]